dann rufe ich auf den tagesordnungspunkt
8 abgabe einer regierungserklärung durch
die bundeskanzlerin zum europäischen rat
am 24 25
juni 20 21 für die aussprache im
anschluss an die regierungserklärung
wurde eine dauer von 60 minuten
beschlossen
das hat das wort zur abgabe der
regierungserklärung die bundeskanzlerin
angela merkel
präsident klebe kolleginnen und kollegen
meine damen und herren
seit gut eineinhalb jahren hält uns die
bekämpfung der korona virus pandemie in
atem national wie international im
rahmen der g7 und der g20 staaten wie
auch natürlich insbesondere im kreis der
eu mitgliedsstaaten
mittlerweile dürfen wir in europa
vorsichtig optimistisch sein denn nicht
nur in deutschland sondern in nahezu
allen europäischen mitgliedstaaten gehen
die infektionszahlen deutlich zurück und
steigt gleichsam im gegenzug die zahl
der geimpften menschen immer weiter an
doch auch wenn es also grund zur
zuversicht gibt vorbei ist die pandemie
noch nicht und schon gar nicht in den
armen ländern dieser welt aber auch wir
in deutschland und europa bewegen uns
immer noch auf dünnem eis
wir müssen weiter wachsam bleiben
besonders neu aufkommende virusvarianten
jetzt vor allem die delta variante man
uns weiterhin zur vorsicht
deshalb müssen wir den weg aus der
pandemie weiter mit augenmaß gehen und
vier themen stehen im mittelpunkt auch
der beratung heute beim beginnenden
europäischen rat
erstens das digitale kopie zertifikat
wir haben uns ja im mai gemeinsam mit
dem europäischen parlament auf ein
europaweit gültiges format geeinigt das
war ein wichtiges signal und technisch
wurde das zertifikat rechtzeitig zur
sommerzeit umgesetzt ab dem ersten juli
wird es eu-weit verbindlich gelten
deutschland hat seinen nationalen
hausaufgaben gemacht dank dafür allen
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern
inzwischen wurden bereits fast 30
millionen digitale zertifikate vergeben
genauer genommen gestern abend sagte mir
der gesundheitsminister um 20 uhr
29,2 millionen zertifikate
damit werden wir unserem anspruch
gerecht ein gemeint
europäischen standards sowohl für gamer
also auch für getest als auch für
getestete und für genesene zu schaffen
dabei entscheiden die eu mitgliedstaaten
weiterhin selbst welche rechte sie dann
den inhabern ist der digitalen
zertifikats einräumen wollen zweitens
der fortschritt der in kampagnen und die
weltweite verteilung von impfstoffen
auch darüber werden wir auf dem heute
beginnenden europäischen rat beraten
bereits beim g7-gipfel in cornwall vor
zwei wochen haben wir hierzu and starkes
zeichen gesetzt wir wissen die pandemie
kann nur global besiegt werden und der
schlüssel dazu ist die impfung und es
ist daher wichtig dass die g7-staaten
bis 2022 die verteilung von 2,3
milliarden impfdosen an
entwicklungsländer ermöglichen wollen
richtig ist und bleibt im übrigen die
entscheidung die impfstoffe in europa
gemeinsam zu beschaffen ich will das
hier noch einmal betonen alles andere
hätte vielleicht kurzzeitig einigen
mitgliedsstaaten vorteile verschafft das
leben in einem gemeinsamen binnenmarkt
aber empfindlich gestört
die europäische union das kann man gar
nicht oft genug sagen war bislang und
bleibt weiterhin der weltweit größte
exporteur von impfstoffen wir haben
unsere märkte nicht geschlossen und
keine barrieren aufgebaut deutschland
ist mit 2,2 milliarden euro zudem der
weltweit zweitgrößte geber des acp axel
watter und hat von diesen 2,2 milliarden
euro 1,6 milliarden für die impfstoff
solle der internationalen allianz kovacs
bereitgestellt und wir haben beschlossen
dass wir zusätzlich 30 millionen
impfdosen bis zum ende des jahres
abgeben werden auch vorrangig für kofax
außerdem müssen wir als eu daran
arbeiten die globale impfstoff
produktion weiter zu erhöhen
deutschland engagiert sich hier aktiv
gemeinsam mit südafrika als coach in der
hochrangigen arbeitsgruppe die kovacs
dafür gebildet hat ich bin überzeugt
dass wir schnellstmöglich die produktion
von impfstoffen auf der basis von
lizenzen vergrößern müssen eine
politisch erwirkte freigabe der patente
halte ich dagegen für den falschen weg
denn so wie wir heute schnellstmöglich
impfstoffe für alle weltweit brauchen so
werden wir auch in zukunft weiter darauf
angewiesen sein dass impfstoffe
entwickelt werden das wird nur gelingen
wenn der schutz geistigen eigentums
nicht außer kraft gesetzt wird sondern
gewahrt bleibt
ich begrüße auch unsere gemeinsame team
europe initiative zur förderung der
produktionsausweitung in afrika die die
eu mit insgesamt einer milliarde euro
unterstützen möchte diese investitionen
in infrastruktur produktionskapazitäten
ausbildung und vieles mehr sind der
richtige weg um afrika mehr mittel zur
selbsthilfe an die hand zu geben und das
gilt dann später natürlich auch für
andere impfstoffe und nicht nur für die
gegen korona drittens erste lehren aus
der krise
dazu hat die europäische kommission
vergangene woche für die diskussion beim
europäischen rat eine mitteilung
vorgelegt in der sie ihre sicht der
dinge darlegt wir mitgliedstaaten werden
bei der diskussion unserer erfahrungen
hinzufügen
klar ist dabei ebenso lande die pandemie
nicht überwunden ist kann eine debatte
über lehren aus der krise nur ein erster
schritt eines längeren und
tiefergehenden prozesses sein aber
dieser prozess ist wichtig denn die
fähigkeit und die bereitschaft dazu
werden darüber entscheiden wie die
europäische union künftige
herausforderungen dieser größenordnung
meistern wird und zwar wie ihr das von
beginn an gemeinsam gelingen kann
denn in der partie haben im ersten stock
zunächst nationale anstrengungen unser
handeln bestimmt bevor wir europäisch
abgestimmt vorgegangen sind
wir wissen heute dass wir das besser
können und jetzt auch in zukunft besser
machen werden
deshalb sehe ich insbesondere in der
krisenreaktion im gesundheitsschutz bei
schengen und im binnenmarkt die bereiche
in denen wir über eine stärkung der
europäischen handlungsfähigkeit
diskutieren müssen
es ist wichtig dass wir das gespräch
darüber bei diesem europäischen rat
beginnen die koordinierung der ebenso
einschneidenden
die im wortsinne notwendigen
zweizügigkeit beschränkende maßnahmen
kamen viel zu zögerlich in gang
das muss im falle eines falles in
zukunft schneller gehen
dennoch denn auch das muss man sagen
heute noch gelingt ist nicht ausreichend
einreisen aus drittstaaten insbesondere
aus virusvarianten gebieten zu
koordinieren und das werde ich dort auch
sehr kritisch anmerken
das muss besser werden gerade in einem
bereich der wie die freizügigkeit zu den
wichtigsten und zugleich sensibelsten
errungenschaften der europäischen
einigung gehört die europäische
kommission macht auch vorschläge für
eine verbesserte krisenvorsorge und
krisenreaktion im bereich der
öffentlichen gesundheitsvorsorge
deutschland unterstützt die schrittweise
schaffung einer gesundheits union und
die entstehung einer neuen
gesundheitsbehörde health im erd und die
preparedness and response or idee
einfach gesagt herr am 4
die wirtschaftliche erholung nach der
pandemie auch darüber wollen wir auf dem
europäischen rat beraten
mit der einigung auf den europäischen
aufbauplan next generation eu hat die
europäische union in der korona virus
panini ihre solidarität und ihre
handlungsfähigkeit unter beweis gestellt
auf eine außergewöhnliche krise haben
wir als europäische union eine
außergewöhnliche antwort gegeben
wir denn auch einen euro gipfel haben im
sogenannten inklusiven format das heißt
alle mitgliedstaaten nehmen daran teil
und auf diesem gipfel berlin werden wir
die diskussion über den wirtschaftlichen
aufbau nach der pandemie fortsetzen und
zum stand der banken union und
kapitalmarkt union diskutieren die
finanzminister haben das vorbereitet und
der euro gruppen vorsitzende wird
anwesend sein
nach der ratifizierung des eigenmittel
beschlusses durch alle mitgliedstaaten
der europäischen union und ich danke an
dieser stelle dem deutschen bundestag
noch einmal für die unterstützung ist
die europäische kommission jetzt in der
lage und ermächtigt durch die
mitgliedstaaten am finanzmarkt kapital
aufzunehmen
auch der deutsche plan wurde vor zwei
tagen von der kommission positiv
bewertet und ist jetzt im rat zur
annahme vorgelegt die ersten 20
milliarden euro sind von der
europäischen kommission platziert die
meisten mitgliedsstaaten haben ihren
nationalen aufbau und resilienz pläne
vorgelegt einige soeben auch der
deutsche sind bereits von der
europäischen kommission bewertet worden
aber ich will noch einmal darauf
hinweisen es bleibt bei dem was wir
letztes jahr beschlossen haben und
verabredet haben bevor mittel fließen
können ist es entscheidend dass die
jeweiligen nationalen aufbau und
resilienz pläne auch tatsächlich
sorgfältig zukunftsorientiert und
innovativ aufgesetzt werden und darauf
werden wir auch bei der weiteren
begutachtung durch den rat achten denn
es gilt ja mit diesem geld nicht nur zu
investieren
sondern gleichzeitig zu reformen wir
müssen den aufbauplan nutzen um
entscheidende weichen für europas
zukunft zu stellen und versäumtes
nachholen und deshalb werden
schwerpunkte für den wiederaufbau vor
allem die grüne erneuerung und die
digitalisierung sein denn wir wissen
dass europa erst mit dem übergang zu
einer digitalisierten grünen wirtschaft
wirklich zukunftsfähig und
wettbewerbsfähig sein wird meine damen
und herren gerade heute da sich der weg
aus der chemie abzuzeichnen beginnt ist
es wichtig dass wir uns auf dem
europäischen rat neben der
wirtschaftlichen erholung auch verstärkt
den anderen themen zuwenden die für
europa von besonderer bedeutung sind und
dazu gehört natürlich auch das thema der
migration
wir dürfen bei der reform der
gemeinsamen europäischen asylpolitik und
des europäischen asylsystems nicht
nachlassen so schwierig diese diskussion
auch ist sie wird noch eine ganze weile
weitergehen
ich begrüße daher sehr dass wir der
einrichtung einer europäischen asyl
agentur einen schritt näher gekommen
unser augenmerk beim europäischen rat
wird diesmal auf der zusammenarbeit mit
herkunfts und transitländern liegen dazu
sollte der europäische rat die
europäische kommission und dem
europäischen ausland hin dienst damit
beauftragen konkrete schritte und
zeitlinien für migrations
partnerschaften mit schlüsselländern
vorzulegen
zudem erwarten wir von der europäischen
kommission einen konkreten vorschlag für
die nachfolge finanzierung der
migrations zusammenarbeit der eu mit der
türkei
in der türkei sind 3,7 millionen
syrische flüchtlinge registriert und es
ist klar dass wir die gegenwärtigen und
anstehenden migrationsfragen nur im
dialog mit der türkei lösen können so
sollten wir jetzt wie wir es bereits im
märz auch vereinbart hatten als
europäische union die dialog agenda mit
der türkei rasche umsetzen umso
zusammenarbeit bei gemeinsamen
interessen voranzubringen
dazu zählt auch dass wir mit unseren
gesprächen zur modernisierung der
zollunion weiterkommen auch die themen
gesundheit klimaschutz und der kampf
gegen den terror gehören dazu
diese strategische zusammenarbeit
sollten wir voranbringen
obwohl wir mit der türkei gravierende
differenzen im bereits reicht der
rechtsstaatlichkeit und der einhaltung
der grundrechte haben ein weiteres
strategisches außenpolitisches thema ist
unser verhältnis zu russland
dazu werden wir auf dem europäischen rat
unsere diskussionen die wir im mai
begonnen haben fortsetzen
die europäische kommission und der
europäische auswärtige dienst haben ein
diskussionspapier vorgelegt dass
insbesondere den stand der beziehungen
analysiert ich wünsche mir dass wir beim
europäischen rat dabei nicht stehen
bleiben denn die ereignisse der letzten
monate und nicht nur in deutschland
haben deutlich gezeigt dass es nicht
reicht wenn wir auf die vielzahl
russischer provokationen und koordiniert
reagieren
stattdessen müssen wir mechanismen
schaffen um wir waren gemeinsam und
vereint auf provokationen antworten zu
können
nur so werden wir lernen den hybriden
angriffen russlands etwas
entgegenzusetzen
gleichzeitig müssen wir eine agenda
gemeinsamer strategischer interessen
definieren
zum beispiel im bereich des
klimaschutzes aber natürlich auch in den
bereichen von frieden und sicherheit wie
bei der lösung der lage in libyen und
syrien
dabei steht außer zweifel die
europäische union ist oft grund ihrer
räumlichen nähe und ihrer verantwortung
gegenüber den ländern in der ersten
partnerschaft zb in der ukraine oder
belarus und auf den westbalkan gefordert
eine angemessene antwort auf die
russischen aktivitäten zu geben
meines erachtens müssen wir dazu als
europäische union auch den direkten
kontakt mit russland und dem russischen
präsidenten suchen
es reicht nicht aus wenn der
amerikanische präsident joe biden mit
dem russischen präsidenten spricht das
begrüße ich sehr
aber die europäische union muss hier
auch gesprächsformat schaffen anders
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir haben
uns bereits auf dem g7-gipfel vom 11 bis
13 juni in cornwall und beim nato gipfel
am 14 juni umfangreich über den umgang
mit russland und auch mitschüler
ausgetauscht seit dem letzten g 7 gipfel
2009 10 in biarritz ist die welt
wahrlich nicht ruhiger geworden die
vielzahl der gräfin weltweit macht eine
enge abstimmung unter den partnern
notwendiger denn je
und daher war es nun besonders wichtig
dass die g7 sich in diesem jahr als
geschlossenes werte bündnis gezeigt
haben dass entschieden und gemeinsam für
den multilateralismus eintritt dazu
gehört dem der diskussion war russland
natürlich auch die frage der beziehung
zu china
die g7 will und muss gemeinsam mit china
an lösungen für globale
herausforderungen arbeiten und
gleichzeitig sind wir als g7 überzeugt
mit unserem gemeinsamen werten und
interessen vielen ländern auf der welt
ein besseres kooperationsangebot als
china machen zu können
so wollen wir als er sieben zb
entwicklungsländer im rahmen einer
partnerschaft durch nachhaltige
infrastruktur finanzierung unterstützen
eine task-force task force wird hierzu
konkrete vorschläge erarbeiten
deutschland wird im nächsten jahr den g7
vorsitz haben und dann
ergebnisse vorliegen ein weiteres
wichtiges thema des g 7 gebiss war der
schutz des klimas und der biodiversität
der die palmi darf das wissen wir ja
auch hier bei uns zu hause nicht davon
ablenken dass wir hier vor einer
gewaltigen globalen herausforderung
stehen es geht um nicht mehr und nicht
weniger als die zukunft unseres planeten
es ist daher gut dass die g7 staaten ein
gemeinsames bekenntnis zur
klimaneutralität des spätestens 2050
abgegeben haben und wir gehen ja in
deutschland darüber noch hinaus
die cops 26 in glasgow wird zeigen wie
weit wir mit unseren verpflichtungen
dann gekommen sind
die g7 staaten erhöhen auch die
internationale klimafinanzierung
perspektivisch wird deutschland seinen
beitrag zur internationalen
klimafinanzierung von heute 4 milliarden
euro bis spätestens 2025 auf sechs
milliarden euro jährlich erhöhen und das
ist ein ganz ganz wichtiges signal der
glaubwürdigkeit und auch beim nato
gipfel am 14 juni stand die
multilaterale zusammenarbeit im
mittelpunkt der gipfel hat der allianz
die gelegenheit gegeben ein neues
kapitel in der transatlantischen
zusammenarbeit aufzuschlagen und die in
den weg für die strategie auf
strategische ausrichtung der nato auf
die kommende dekade zu weisen
das findet seinen ausdruck in dem
auftrag bis zum gipfel in spanien 2022
ein neues strategisches konzept
auszuarbeiten und ein maßnahmepaket nato
2030 anzunehmen ich möchte thomas de
maizière für seine vorarbeiten im rahmen
des berichts der reflexionsgruppe hier
einmal herzlich danken
für all dem ist aus meiner sicht
entscheidend dass die nato ihre
kernaufgaben und die primären
herausforderungen fest im blick hat
dies sind für mich vor allem russland
aber auch die konflikte und die
fragilität in unserer nachbarschaft sei
es in zentralasien nahost und nordafrika
und dem st und natürlich gilt es den
bedrohungen aus dem cyberspace raum zu
begegnen und der zunehmenden bedeutung
chinas angemessen rechnung zu tragen
das liegt in unserem unmittelbaren
deutschen und europäischen interesse
denn die nato ist und bleibt die
unersetzliche garantin der sicherheit
und stabilität in europa daher
daher wird deutschland weiter seinen
beitrag dazu leisten politisch und
militärisch und deswegen bleibt es auch
notwendig dass wir die anstrengungen
hinsichtlich unserer
verteidigungsausgaben konsequent
fortsetzen um unseren
bündnisverpflichtungen und unser
sicherheitsverantwortung für unser land
und europa nachkommen zu können
immer mehr mitgliedsstaaten immer mehr
mitgliedstaaten in der nato erreichen
dass in wales ins auge gefasste 2% ziert
deutschland wird hierbei in den nächsten
jahren weiter gefordert sein
meine damen und herren die hinter uns
liegt ein monat mit vielen neuen
multilateralen impulsen
ich bin überzeugt dass wir nur zusammen
als staatengemeinschaft erfolgreich die
herausforderung der pandemie wie auch
der anderen großen aufgaben meistern
können eine souveräne europäische union
sollte hier ein starker partner sein und
daran den wir heute und morgen auch in
brüssel aber herzlichen dank
hart sei es eine regierungserklärung
gewesen wie jeder andere auch ist es
aber natürlich nicht es war die
mutmaßlich letzte dieser
legislaturperiode aber auch in ihrer
ganzen 16 jährigen amtszeit am schluss
schien sie noch ein klein wenig doch
noch mal zu schlucken aber das ist
natürlich eine interpretation aus der
ferne auffällig wie viel applaus es
jetzt gibt relativ lang für eine
regierungserklärung und jetzt dreht sich
da vielleicht hinter dieser maske doch
die eine oder andere im netz emotion
auch bei der applaus und auch das ist
ungewöhnlich ist ein wenig rhythmus
wurde
ende diese regierungserklärung zum
europäischen rat der heute und morgen
stattfindet wird jetzt erwidert oder auf
diese regierungserklärung von alice
weidl hf die fraktion
sehr geehrter präsident sehr geehrte
frau bundeskanzlerin sehr geehrte damen
und herren auch diese
regierungserklärung ist vorbei gegangen
die alle anderen ohne ein funken
einsicht in die fehlentscheidung die
ihren weg als kanzlerin zäune
fehlentscheidungen die dieses land tief
gespalten und in schweren schaden auf
jahre und jahrzehnte hinaus zugefügt
haben und sie wollen diesen weg bis zum
bitteren ende fortsetzen
das dürfen wir ihren ausführungen zum
bevorstehenden eu-gipfel entnehmen ein
ernstes betreiben sie die erneuerung des
migrations abkommens der eu mit der
türkei
das ist nichts anderes als die
neuauflage eines historischen
fehlschlags die eu erneuert damit ihre
erpressbarkeit sie zahlt und bittet
dafür den deutschen steuerzahler zur
kasse
sie macht sich von den launen des
türkischen präsidenten abhängig der die
migrations schleusen weiter nach
belieben auf und zudrehen kann der
schlüssel zur eindämmung der illegalen
migration nicht aber nicht in ankara
er liegt in berlin hier werden mit den
höchsten sozialhilfe setzen menschen
auch die gefährliche überfahrt gelockt
werden schleuser die a 10 o trainieren
sogar von kirchen gesponsert und hier
werden die signale gesendet das so gut
wie keiner der es zu und schafft je
wieder gehen muss stellen sie also diese
signale ab und schützen sie die
deutschen grenzen gegen illegale
migranten frau von der leyen reist
gerade mit dem scheckbuch durch die
europäischen hauptstädte und verteilt
milliarden aus dem sogenannten corona
wiederaufbau von auch in berlin hat sie
1 24 milliarden scheck vorbeigebracht
geld das wir die register
klimaschutzmaßnahme mit fragwürdigem
nutzen verpulvert werden wird der
angebliche wiederaufbau von ist die
tarnkappe für die einführung der
europäischen schulden union die eu
kommission kann jetzt selbst anleihen
aufnehmen und das geld nach gutdünken
verteilen
für die rückzahlung stehen die
nationalstaaten gerade ein voran
deutschland und seine steuerzahler
ihnen wird die kontrolle über die
eigenen staatsfinanzen und diesem
parlament das budgetrecht zug um zug
entwunden und auch für diesen anschlag
auf die grundprinzipien der
demokratischen ordnung für diesen
anschlag auf das parlamentarische
budgetrecht und der rechtsstaatlichkeit
tragen sie die verantwortung und das ist
ein weiterer düsterer meilenstein in der
langen serie der historischen
fehlentscheidung ihrer 16-jährigen
kanzlerschaft bedenkenlos missbrauchen
sie die korona krise um diesen
souveränitäts transfer an die eu zu
bemänteln den staatlichen einfluss auf
wirtschaft und gesellschaft auszuweiten
und den übergang zu einer gelenkten
klimaschutz planwirtschaft zu forcieren
auf kosten der energiewirtschaft auf
kosten der automobilbranche der
investitionsgüterindustrie also dort wo
die meisten arbeitsplätze sind ihre
krone politik ist ihr größter fehler der
letzten zeit und deswegen klammern sie
sich auch so verbissen daran fest um
verweigern
leider jeden erkenntnisfortschritt
unsere europäischen nachbarn so viel
längst den weg zurück zur normalität und
die deutsche corona politik staat weiter
verklemmt auf incidents werte und schürt
panik für den
herbst mit der beschwörung finsterer
bedrohungsszenarien zu sogenannten delta
variante da muss doch einst festgehalten
werden ihr lockdown und notstands regime
hat für die gesundheit und sicherheit
keine messbaren vorteile gegenüber
alternativen handlungsoption gebracht
aber sie hat gigantische
kolateralschäden in wirtschaft und
gesellschaft angerichtet mittelstand und
mittelschicht schwer geschädigt
existenzen ruiniert kinder und senioren
leiden lassen und eine ganze
schülergenerationen um ihre
bildungschancen gebracht ihre politik
hat mit panikmache und apodiktisch und
schwarz weiß denken das land tief
gespalten
die kluft zwischen arm und reich
vergrößert und die grund und
freiheitsrechte der bürger in bislang
nie dagewesener dimension zur
disposition gestellt die begründung für
diese politik fallen wie die
dominosteine pauschale grundrechts
einschränkungen dauer lockt das sind
nicht nur verfassungswidrig
sie bringen auch nichts und die liste
der beispiele von ländern die ohne
solche drastischen eingriffen besser
durch die krise gekommen sind geht
stetig länger von schweden der schweiz
bis zu einer reihe von us bundesstaaten
ist als unterricht bei monatelangen
geschlossenen schulen ist wirkungslos er
wirft schüler zurück die ewige
sommerferien den von ihnen als general
argument beschworenen notstand in den
kliniken hat es offenkundig auch nicht
gegeben das gesund
eben war zu keinem zeitpunkt bedroht die
gemeldeten zahlen waren von subventions
fehlanreiz ins bundesrechnungshof lesen
sie den von subventions fehlanreizen
ermuntert vielfach manipuliert steht
es steht dem bericht des
bundesrechnungshofes pcr tests sind als
mittel zur massen erkennung
desinfektions geschehens nicht geeignet
jeder zweite positiv getestete
organischen pcs auch das sind die fakten
abrechnungsbetrug bei schnelltests und
dubiose masken viel zeigen vor allem
eins wo staatlicher dirigismus freien
lauf hat sind misswirtschaft
verschwendung und korruption niemals
weit und die milliarden die hier
vergeudet wurde während einer reform der
klinik finanzierung weitaus besser
angelegt gewesen das muss man auch mal
sagen
und dieser ihr weg darf sich im herbst
wenn sich die virusaktivität saisonal
wieder verstärken wird nicht noch einmal
wiederholen
deutschland muss zurückkehren zu einer
politik von vernunft und augenmaß von
bürgerlicher eigenverantwortung
stadtstaats angeschaut und vor allem
brauchen wir 1 wir brauchen eine andere
regierung ich bedanke mich herzlich
der bundestag diskutiert über die
mutmaßlich letzte regierungserklärung
der bundeskanzlerin nach 16 jahren
amtszeit gibt es da gewiss anlass zur
kritik vor allem aus der opposition es
ist aber auch immer eine frage des teams
und des auftretens und deshalb gibt es
hier heute morgen eine ungewöhnliche
rednerliste den
als nächster wird ans pult gehen der
bundesfinanzminister olaf scholz und
auch der ministerpräsident von
nordrhein-westfalen und cdu vorsitzende
armin laschet wird nachher noch in die
debatte eingreifen damen und herren
abgeordnete wir diskutieren in diesen
bundestag wahrscheinlich heute das
letzte mal in größerer runde über die
europa politik und das ist für mich ein
besonderer anlass auch einmal eine
botschaft loszuwerden
ich möchte mich bei der bundeskanzlerin
für die zusammenarbeit in der europa
politik in den letzten vier jahren
bedanken
wir haben viele fortschritte für europa
erreicht das ist nicht
selbstverständlich gewesen und ich
glaube dass es gut für deutschland und
für europa
erinnern wir uns es hat große große
auseinandersetzungen in europa gegeben
in der folge der finanzkrise die durch
den zusammenbruch der bank lehman
brothers losgegangen ist und dann der
große schuldenkrise hat viele länder
europas bedroht es hat große große
schwierigkeiten gegeben
bei einer gemeinsamen antwort europas
auf die herausforderung als viele
flüchtlinge nach europa gekommen sind
und es so schwer war an einem gemeinsam
weg in der auseinandersetzung mit dieser
situation zu formulieren
aber in dieser krise in der korona
pandemie und in der antwort hat europa
nach anfänglichen rubbeln es geschafft
eine gemeinsame antwort zu finden und
das ist richtig so
[Applaus]
die entscheidung die im letzten jahr
getroffen worden sind und die jetzt
praktisch und zug um zug zu ende
gebracht werden
die entscheidungen haben möglich gemacht
dass europa auf diese krise ökonomisch
gemeinsam reagiert wir haben ein
paradigmenwechsel organisiert der
tatsächlich dazu beitragen wird dass
europa stärker und souveräner wird genau
das was wichtig ist für unsere
gemeinsame zukunft
[Applaus]
europa bekämpft die krise gemeinsam und
wir spüren die folgen jetzt schon alles
was wir jetzt wo die pandemie so
allmählich sich verflüchtigt wir immer
noch vorsichtig sein müssen aber doch
feststellen können dass wir eine
situation erreichen und der dieser
sommer anders wird und der immer mehr
bürgerinnen und bürger geimpft sind
alles was dabei rausgekommen es ist ein
aufschwung den wir in deutschland und
europa haben ein aufschwung der
wahrscheinlich größer sein wird als wir
ihnen heute voraus berechnen können und
das ist das ergebnis der gemeinsamen
krisenbekämpfung europa wird gemeinsam
handeln in dem die europäische union
kredite aufnimmt keine
selbstverständliche entscheidung was für
aufgeregte debatten sind zu diesem thema
in den letzten jahren und jahrzehnten in
europa geführt worden und auch
hierzulande und wie wenig aufgeregt
waren diese debatten in dem letzten und
in diesem jahr
da hat es einen gemeinsamen
erkenntnisfortschritt gegeben der lautet
in einer welt von bald zehn milliarden
einwohnern in einer welt die geprägt
sein wird von vielen starken
wirtschaftlichen mächten den usa
selbstverständlich china vielen
aufstrebenden nationen asiens und
manchen anderen in dieser welt wird es
nicht möglich sein dass jedes
europäische land für sich alleine
zurechtkommt wir werden es nur
miteinander und deshalb brauchen wir
auch starke instrumente um gemeinsam
handeln zu können
[Applaus]
die kreditaufnahme der union hat
begonnen
und sie hatten auch erfolg gehabt sie
ist gut funktioniert sie wird uns in die
lage versetzen wenn jetzt stück für
stück die aufbauprogramme der
verschiedenen länder akzeptiert und
genehmigt werden von der kommission um
von dem rat dass dann der fortschritt
beginnt bei der digitalisierung bei der
bekämpfung des menschengemachten
klimawandels und das ist gut für die
modernisierung der europäischen union
für mich ist aber damit auch verbunden
dass wir nicht nur das erste mal diese
kreditaufnahme haben sondern dass wir
zwei entscheidungen damit verbunden
haben die mindestens genauso wichtig
sind nämlich dass die aufgenommenen
kredite auch zurückgezahlt werden und
dass es eigene einnahmen der
europäischen union geben soll
um diese kreditaufnahme zurückzuführen
zwei entscheidungen für eine stärkere
souveränität europas genau kraft
ausgebrochen
und deshalb kann es auch aus dieser
krone pandemie und angesichts der
tagesordnung die der liga jetzt für uns
alle
besprochen wird kann es an diesen
angesichts dieser tatsache nur eine
konsequenz aus allen geben
wir müssen verstehen dass europa noch
stärker wird wenn wir es politisch
begreifen wenn dort mehr politik gemacht
wird
europa ist nicht nur ein binnenmarkt den
wir vollenden europa ist politisch
europa muss politische fragen lösen wie
zum beispiel die frage wie wir umgehen
mit den herausforderungen der migration
dass es ein thema dieses gipfels aber
auch mit der frage wie wir eine neue
europäische ost politik entwickeln die
auch möglich macht dass wir in auf
diesem kontinent insbesondere auch mit
russland eine gemeinsame perspektive
gemeinsamer sicherheit entwickeln können
beides große themen für die zukunft
[Applaus]
und für mich geht es auch darum dass wir
begreifen dass wir in der europäischen
union zusammen gekommen sind weil wir
auch gemeinsame überzeugungen und werte
haben
das ist nicht nur ein zweckbündnis und
schon gar nicht nur wegen der wirtschaft
und des binnenmarktes
wir haben auch etwas das uns gemeinsam
trägt nämlich überzeugung über
demokratie und rechtsstaatlichkeit und
ich will in diesen tagen ganz
ausdrücklich sagen wir sind auch
zusammen gekommen weil wir uns dazu
bekennen dass wir liberale demokratien
sind das ist das was uns auszeichnet
europa ist ein bündnis offener
gesellschaft
die welt ist nicht einfach und sie wird
vermutlich auch nicht leicht friedlicher
und in der welt gibt es regierung mit
denen wir nichts gemein haben aber
vieles wo wir vieles unterschiedlich
sind
mit denen müssen wir uns auch streiten
wenn es darum geht wie wir gemeinsame
sicherheit in der welt schaffen können
in der europäischen union gibt es einen
unterschied
und der ist wichtig wir haben uns
verständigt was uns miteinander zusammen
führt an rechtsstaatlichkeit an schutz
von minderheiten an offenheit und dieses
bekenntnis zur liberalen demokratie ist
deshalb auch immer ein streitpunkt
untereinander und das sage ich
ausdrücklich das gilt auch insbesondere
wenn es um die rechte zum beispiel von
schwulen und lesben geht wir müssen da
dann auch in europa miteinander stark
und deutlich diskutieren rechts sind
etwas was zur demokratie dazugehört und
wir müssen klar sein und
unmissverständlich schön war
der bundesfinanzminister
olaf scholz mit einer europapolitischen
rede denn vergessen wir eines nicht er
bewirbt sich ja auch um die nachfolge
von angela merkel als bundeskanzler ist
kanzlerkandidat der spd und dem deshalb
nicht zuletzt deshalb an und diese
position in der rednerliste gerutscht
ihm wird jetzt folgen christian lindner
der vorsitzende der fdp-fraktion im
bundestag und parteivorsitzender ist er
ja bekanntlich auch geteilt es wurden
vorsitzende der fdp fraktion christian
timm
vielen dank herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
bundeskanzlerin heute haben sie die
voraussichtlich letzte
regierungserklärung zu einem
europäischen rat abgegeben historiker
werden dereinst bewerten was in ihrer
kanzlerschaft erreicht wurde und was
versäumt wurde
aber eines kann man heute sagen sie
haben in den vergangenen 16 jahren ihre
kraft und ihre intellektuellen gaben
stets uneigennützig in den dienst
deutschlands und europas gestellt und
damit haben sie sich große verdienste
erworben
die rednerin die rednerin der afg hat
über fehlentscheidungen gesprochen eine
wesentliche fehlentscheidung hat sie
aber vergessen nämlich die
fehlentscheidung des fdp
bundesparteitags dass deutschland aus
der europäischen union austreten sollen
konsequenterweise frau doktor bei
konsequenter weise hätten sie dann hier
auf ihrer rede auch gleich verzichten
können es hat sich niemand zum vorwurf
gemacht
uns ist klar die angeblich genscher
gesagt hat europa ist unsere zukunft wir
haben keine andere messen müssen wir uns
als parteien des demokratischen zentrums
hier gewiss nicht vergewissern
diese debatte hier hat aber einen
anderen charakter wie die rede liste
zeigt es ist keine debatte die die
gegenwart oder die vergangenheit
bewertet sondern beispielsweise ja auch
gerade der beitrag des
bundesfinanzministers weist nach vorne
denn er hat hier gesprochen als kandidat
für die kanzlerschaft
deshalb wird man frau berbalk dann
laschet und herrn scholz auch hier in
dieser debatte daran messen müssen was
sie für die zukunft konzeptionell sagen
herr scholz der zentrale und wesentliche
punkt ihrer rede war doch das
schuldenmachen zur neuen
staatsphilosophie zu verklären next
generation eu ist eine antwort auf die
krise auf diese pandemie gewesen dass
jetzt eine konditionalität gibt bei der
auszahlung der mittel das verdankt sich
nicht der deutschen bundesregierung das
verdankt sich beispielsweise herrnhütte
und herrn kurs bei der bewertung der
konditionalität
bei der bewertung der konditionalität
ist es beklagenswert dass italien mit 44
reformvorschlägen aufwarten kann
deutschland aber nur mit 14 da haben sie
die latte gerissen
nun stellt sich nach vornehmen die frage
wie wird das zukünftig sein
dieses next generation eu war von frau
merkel und ihnen herrn scholz zusammen
mit der französischen regierung in
hammerbrook geplant gewesen von
rückzahlung war dort keine rede von
reformvorhaben war dort keine rede
erst durch die intervention der
sparsamen 4 kam es zu dieser anderen im
übrigen richtigen anlage nun stellt sich
die frage an armin laschet
wenn er den anspruch auf die
kanzlerschaft erhebt wo wird deutschland
zukünftig stehen werden wir vertreter
einer eher mediterran geprägten
fiskalpolitik in europa sein oder wird
deutschland wieder anwalt von stabilität
und marktwirtschaft in europa sein
diese frage stellt sich diese
entschuldigung diese diese frage stellt
sich jeder kann sie für sich beantworten
aber sie muss beantwortet werden für uns
ist klar
staatsschulden sind eine gefahr für die
stabilität der wirtschafts und
währungsunion die krise von vor zehn
jahren ist noch nicht überwunden
die europäische zentralbank ist bisher
nicht in den normalen modus
zurückgekommen inflationsgefahren drohen
und deshalb muss klar sein
finanzpolitische eigenverantwortung der
mitgliedstaaten der europäischen union
ist ein garant für stabilität und für
solidität
die zweite frage die sich stellt
frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben es
angesprochen wie halten wir es zukünftig
mit der migrationspolitik die probleme
und konflikte des jahres 2015 sind
bedauerlicherweise sehr weitgehend
ungelöst das bezeugt die tatsache dass
es neue verabredungen mit der türkei
geben muss wie sich allerdings
inzwischen nun wirklich augenscheinlich
in eine autoritäre präsidial diktatur
gewandt hat horst seehofer hat
tatsächlich richtige initiativen
versucht zu ergreifen bei der deutschen
eu ratspräsidentschaft aber zu einem
grundlegenden beschluss zur verteilung
und rückführung von flüchtlingen ist es
nicht gekommen
es fehlt ein vorteil mechanismus der
veer ist es gibt immer noch verheerende
zustände in den lagern die niemand mit
humanitärem anspruch tolerieren kann die
haben immer noch keine konzepte für
gelingende rückführungen wir haben immer
noch keinen schutz unserer außengrenzen
und hier stellt sich nun die frage wie
wir zukünftig darauf reagiert
es wird insbesondere frau berbalk zu
beantworten haben es waren die grünen
die über jahre etwa die erklärung
einzelne staaten zu sicheren
herkunftsländern zu entscheiden
blockiert haben wie würde das eine
bundeskanzlerin berbalk machen
sie versuchen ja mit ihrer kampagne
erkennbar
von links in die politische mitte zu
ziehen also müssen sie aber auch eine
politik der politischen mitte machen und
da gilt die kontrolle des zugangs zu
einer gesellschaft ist die voraussetzung
für soziale stabilität und für jede
öffentliche ordnung und wir müssen uns
dem klimaschutz freilich widmen
eine große gemeinsame aufgabe die
bundesregierung hat gerade ein klima
paket beschlossen
dieses klima paket verschärft die ziele
für deutschland zu einer zeit als die
neue lastenverteilung innerhalb der
europäischen union die sich aus dem 55%
zähler gibt noch gar nicht beschlossen
ist einseitig setzt sich deutschlands
ziele ohne sie europäisch abzustimmen
mit dem ergebnis dass wir es uns
schwerer machen aber für das weltklima
im zweifel gar nichts erreicht und hier
stellt sich die frage wird deutschland
das zukünftig weiter fortsetzen
gerade in der klimapolitik liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen gilt wir
brauchen mehr europäische gemeinsamkeit
und weniger nationale alleingänge und
der scholz setzt insbesondere mir von
ihren aussagen gewünscht denn ihr
anspruch als sozialdemokratie war es ja
immer auch die interessen der
hochqualifizierten leistungsorientierten
belegschaften der industrie zu vertreten
und dort müsste die sozialdemokratie
doch uns zur kenntnis geben ob sie auch
zukünftig daran fest und warten wir die
deutsche automobilindustrie ohne beitrag
für den klimaschutz einseitig schlechter
zu stellen indem etwa die synthetische
kraftstoffe die im wahlprogramm der cdu
auftauchen nicht auch die flotten
grenzwerte der automobilindustrie
angerechnet werden frau berg hat
deutlich gesagt sie nimmt 200.000
abgebaute arbeitsplätze in der
automobilindustrie hin sie auch darauf
hätten wir eine antwort gewünscht
genauso die frage ob die veränderte und
verschärfte regulatorisch für die
chemieindustrie
eine zustimmung des bundeskanzlers olaf
scholz erfahren würde
wir hätten uns gewünscht von ihnen zu
erfahren ob es mit einem bundeskanzler
scholz eine neue balance gibt zwischen
einerseits den notwendigen ökologischen
veränderungen und investitionen und
andererseits den berechtigten
wirtschaftlichen interessen der
deutschen industrie und ihrer
beschäftigten
dazu haben wir
nichts hört was wir wollen einen
europäischen co2 erlaubnisschein handelt
wir wollen das instrument des co2 markt
auf deutschland und europa ausweiten
sektorübergreifend weil wir dadurch
nämlich eine antwort geben auf die die
welt wartet nämlich dass europa als
technologieführer die innovationen
entwickelt die nicht nur bei uns co2
einsparen sondern die einen
segensreichen beitrag zu einer
menschheitsaufgabe leisten teilt
christian lindner fdp
ja wir sind in der regierungserklärung
von bundeskanzlerin merkel bzw in der
aussprache dazu und zu beginn ihrer
amtszeit stand übrigens ein ganz anderes
thema ein ganz anderes europäisches
thema weit vorne auf der eu agenda
nämlich der verfassungsvertrag für die
europäische union und dessen ablehnung
durch frankreich und die niederlande
nächster redner der ministerpräsident
von nordrhein-westfalen armin laschet
auch parteivorsitzender cdu auch
kanzlerkandidat der union
herr präsident
damen und herren abgeordnete heute ist
er 24 juni und vor
an diesem tag begann die blockade
berlins
das war der angriff auf die freie welt
land und wasser verbindung wurden hier
aus dieser stadt ausgehend unterbrochen
und er versucht den menschen ihre
freiheit zu nehmen ist am ende
gescheitert weil die luftbrücke der
inbegriff der ausgestreckten hand der
usa großbritanniens frankreichs und
weiterer länder war und er hat gezeigt
symbolisch exemplarisch für eine ganze
generation auch als lebensgefühl wenn
liberale demokratien zusammenarbeiten
haben teilung und konfrontation keine
chance und freundschaft
und bündnisse mit anderen demokratien
sind die grundlage des wohlstands und
der erfolg unseres landes und das gilt
vor allem für europa zum einen deshalb
weil wir in einem europa das 27
leistungsfähiger und wettbewerbsfähiger
sind als alleine
ich glaube auch an die stärke der
europäischen idee das eigentliche herz
europas ist doch nicht effizienz soll
ist die idee der freiheit und der
menschenwürde weshalb man sich
zusammengeschlossen hat und diese idee
verbindet uns und deshalb muss dieses
europa nicht mit unbarmherziger kühle
und kersten nicht technokratisch sondern
eher im rahmen verantwortete freiheit
agieren wir brauchen europa wir brauchen
europa mehr als je zuvor
wir stehen an einem epochenwechsel und
das haben wir gerade in der pandemie
nochmals sehr genau gemerkt wir sehen
die große wirtschaftliche dynamik in
asien
wir sehen china wie sehen das
internationale machtgefüge verändert
sich dazu ist eben und das ist bei ihnen
noch nicht angekommen
der nationalstaat alleine zu schwach um
in dieser welt zu bestehen alleine
besser
und wie aroma der klimawandel kommt
hinzu als herausforderung unserer
generation
er ist nur in einer globalen welt
gemeinsam zu schaffen mit europäischen
anstrengungen und die völker
rechtsbrüche in europa die cyber
angriffe auch auf den deutschen
bundestag sind nur bewältigbar es wird
ja den gipfel ob betreffen das
verhältnis zu unseren nachbarn sind nur
lösbar wenn ich 27 nationalstaaten
möglichst noch gegeneinander paktieren
tricksen sondern man mit einer stimme
europas spricht und sagt das lassen wir
uns nicht gefallen
hier ist die europäische position die
dem entgegen gestellt
wenn wir haben das doch erhebt während
der pandemie eine solche sämtlich
stoffmaske wenige cent wert war
plötzlich nicht mehr verfügbar in
unseren operationssälen konnte nicht
mehr operiert werden weil die simpelsten
dinge fehlten weil wir abhängig waren
von einer fremden macht und deshalb ist
es richtig dass der gipfel heute sagt
wie können wir autark werden wie können
wir unsere daseinsvorsorge selbst
sicherstellen
wie können wir impfstoffe herstellen
damit wir dieser welt
das wird ihnen vielleicht gefallen dass
es stellen sich nicht nur um eine welt
vor in der es nur chinesische und
russische impfstoffe geben würde
wie würde das die geopolitische
situation verändern ich bin froh dass
wir in europa impfstoffe entwickelt
haben und dass wir selbst in der lage
sind die welt zu versorgen mit dem was
wissenschaftler und forscher in europa
entwickelt haben das ist der unterschied
dieses selbstbewusstsein was wir
brauchen und deshalb ist eine partei die
deutschland aus der europäischen union
herausführen will sich schaden deutschen
interessen das ist das was ihrer politik
behörden und was sie anstellen mit ihrem
gebrüder
deshalb wollen wir deshalb waren die
letzte woche deshalb waren die letzten
tage gute tage weil die vereinigten
staaten zurückkehren zu multilateralen
lösung weil die vereinigten staaten
europa sagen wir als liberale
demokratien wollen in dieser welt
gemeinsam agieren und jetzt müssen wir
europa aber auch in der lage sein selbst
unsere stärke zu entwickeln
selbst so stark werden dass wir da
handlungsfähig sind das sind wir nicht
in allen
es ist eine große leistung gewesen bin
wieder auf europas mit 750 milliarden zu
starten
ein system zum ersten mal nimmt europa
gemeinsame anleihen auf um eine große
aufgabe zu bewältigen
aber auch hier die erkenntnis
deutschland wird nur stark wenn der
binnenmarkt wieder funktioniert wenn die
anderen auch stark sind und da christian
linden da bin ich nicht sicher ob in
europa unter führung der 4
die lande sich gesträubt haben die lange
den taschenrechner als konzept hatten
und nicht die europäische vision ob
dieses europa in dieser lage da in guten
händen gewesen wäre es ist gut dass
bundeskanzlerin merkel und präsident
marco vorangegangen sind und am ende die
anderen auch überzeugt haben und das ist
besser als wenn die vier vorangegangenen
werden und die anderen den vier gefolgt
werden das war der richtige weg und das
ist der weg den wir auch in zukunft
brauchen
und mediterrane finanzpolitik ist nun
keine finanzpolitische kategorie es
hilft dem kontinent nicht mit solchen
kategorien und adjektiven europäische
finanzpolitik zu bezeichnen als walters
ich bin der festen überzeugung wir
brauchen eine umfassende digitale und
daten union
das ist nicht nur die besteuerung von
unternehmern herr bundesfinanzminister
ist ein wichtiger schritt den man da
erreicht hat aber wir müssen auch das
beste umfeld für die unternehmen
schaffen dass der nächste digitale
champion aus europa kommt und diese
anstrengung wettbewerbsfähigkeit wie sie
die lissabon-strategie einmal benannt
hat wieder zum maßstab europäischer
politik zu machen das ist etwas was ein
wenig zu kurz gekommen ist und wo wir
wieder anknüpfen müssen auch in den
europäischen prozessen und portale die
blockade in fragen der außen und
sicherheitspolitik muss ein ende finden
ich auch das schätze ich es als wichtig
ein dass sich der europäische rat heute
mit russland mit der türkei beschäftigt
dass das migrations abkommen mit der
türkei verlängert wird dass man diesen
weg geht auch mit denen die unsere
nachbarn sind rund um das mittelmeer
gemeinsame lösungen zu finden
aber da brauchen wir auch mehr
mehrheitsentscheidungen in der außen und
sicherheitspolitik wir brauchen flexible
koalitionen der gestaltungs willigen
sonst bleiben wir nur auf der
zuschauertribüne und ich sag mal das hat
immer zwei seiten bei dem ersten satz ja
wir brauchen mehr europa mehr außen und
sicherheitspolitik werden viele bei spd
und grünen sagen ja stimmt mehr europa
weniger nationalstaat
wenn man dann aber europäische etwas
verabredet ein sicherheits projekt macht
die idee alle europäischen drohne und
keiner nationalen drohne entwickelt oder
was auch immer
dann darf man danach nicht im
klein-klein der
innenpolitik wieder sagen aber dieses
und jenes wollen wir jetzt doch nicht
wenn europa dann gemeinsam verantwortung
übernehmen wird dann auch das durch
tragen wenn es möglich ist und lassen
sie mich eine letzte bemerkung machen
die frau bundeskanzlerin hat der welt
dass man heute auch konsequenzen für den
binnenraum und für das schengen system
erörtern will auf dem europäischen rat
und exakt bei dem beispiel haben wir
erlebt dass immer noch weltkrise kommt
wenn eine neue situation da ist der alte
nationalstaatliche reflex da ist man
glaubt der ernsthaft man könne ein virus
bekämpfen
mit dem schließen von grenzen mit
schlagbäumen mit zollbeamten und hat an
den grenzen wo das geschehen es
plötzlich bei den menschen gemerkt dass
sie längst weiter waren dass sie nicht
verstanden warum man nicht in straßburg
nach kehl über die europabrücke fahren
darf wenn man einen guten grund dafür
hat das war ein fehler das war ein
fehler
wir haben es war ein fehler wir es war
nicht nur herr söder kretschmann und es
waren ein paar mehr
wir haben alle gelernt aus dieser ersten
situation wir haben gelernt die
nordrhein-westfälische niederländische
und belgische grenze war übrigens die
ganze zeit offen wir haben gekämpft
dafür dass diese grenze offen bleibt und
dann nämlich
es muss entwickelt mit dem partner
jenseits der grenze gemeinsam in einer
ad hoc arbeitsgruppe uns zu informieren
dreimal die woche zu tagen die
gesundheitsämter alle die dafür
verantwortlich sind und gemeinsam auf
die krise zu reagieren in der zweiten
dritten welle war das konsens und das
muss eine lehre sein wir dürfen diesen
binnenmarkt nicht wieder durch
grenzschließungen zerstören der gipfel
wird sich damit beschäftigen wie der
binnenmarkt wieder konsequent
hergestellt wird und deshalb ist das
nicht nur ein politischer prozess ist
nicht nur ein politischer prozess es ist
eine lebenseinstellung weder von einem
tödlichen virus noch vor
antieuropäischer helmut skepsis und es
richtig von populisten und nationalisten
lassen wir uns dieses europa kaputt
macht das ist die ansage an sie und an
alle die das tor
der ministerpräsident von nordrhein
westfalen cdu vorsitzende und
kanzlerkandidat der union keine
aussprache zu einer regierungserklärung
wie jeder andere ist es die wohl letzte
zu einer von angela merkel und es ist
auch ein forum für die bewerber und
bewerberinnen um die nachfolge der
kanzlerin und deswegen werden wir als
über nächste rednerin hier auch annalena
baerbock gehören die kanzlerkandidatin
von bündnis 90 die grünen der nächste
redner aber der hier auf der liste steht
wird dietmar bartsch sein co
vorsitzender der linksfraktion hier
jetzt bittet die unionsabgeordneten
mögen doch aufhören mit dem applaus für
armin laschet jetzt das wort ja sonst
vorsitzende der fraktion die linke
dietmar bartsch damen und herren selten
so viel beifall von der rede bekommen
frau bundeskanzlerin nach 16 jahren ist
der anstehende europäische rat
voraussichtlich letzter wenn ich die
reden gehört habe muss ich sehr stark
dass voraussichtlich betonen da nicht
vermutet die regierungsbildung wird doch
noch länger dauern als beim letzten mal
wenn ich die doch sehr unterschiedlichen
positionen hier gehört hat die
europäische union sehr geehrte frau
bundeskanzlerin ist meter mit dem ende
ihrer amtszeit in keinem guten zustand
denn was ist denn der maßstab der
maßstab ist was die menschen in den
europäischen ländern nicht nur darüber
denken sondern wie ihre situation ist
und da sagen alle betragen
das für eine sehr problematische doch
nun sind und wenn ich daran erinnern
darf was zu beginn der pandemie heute
vor einem jahr los war hat ebenso garmin
asche darüber gesprochen grenzen wurden
zugemacht und ähnliches da hat man
gesehen wie gefährlich die situation ist
und ehrlich gesagt dass gemeinsam das
mag sich ja danach entwickelt haben aber
da haben wir die riesengroße gefahr
gesehen der unendlich vielen
alleingängen und ich will da sie zu den
impfstoffen der bemerkung gemacht haben
auch noch mal etwas dazu sagen alles ist
ja sehr gut das ist jetzt vereinbart
werden soll 2 3 milliarden dosen dass es
völlig in ordnung aber sie haben sich
noch einmal ausdrücklich dagegen
ausgesprochen dass die patente
freigegeben werden sollen
ich will noch mal deutlich sagen niemand
hier im deutschen bundestag fordert dass
patente allgemein und grundsätzlich frei
gegeben werden weil dann forschung
behindert wird das überhaupt nicht die
position aber wenn eine krise ist und es
geht um leben und tod dann muss man
besondere entscheidungen treffen und
deshalb ist die vorgehaltenen richtig
wie gesagt haben
die bundeskanzlerin im letzten jahr
hatte deutschland hatten sie die
europäische ratspräsidentschaft und sie
haben damals gesagt die höchste
priorität der deutschen
ratspräsidentschaft ist es dass europa
gab ein und gestärkt aus der krise kommt
aber wir wollen europa nicht nur
kurzfristig stabilisieren das wäre zu
wenig wir wollen auch ein europa das
hoffnung macht wir wollen ein europa das
zukunftsfähige ist wir wollen einen
aufbruch für europa und ich kann dem nur
voll inhaltlich zu stimmen armin laschet
hat gesagt europa mehr denn je aber
ehrlich gesagt diesen anspruch den sie
formuliert haben den haben sie nicht
eingelöst europa ist
keiner phase des aufbruchs in europa
taumelt dem plan wie ein angeschlagener
boxer vor dem körper von einer ecke in
die andere und vor allen dingen vor dem
ko stehen die ganz normalen bürgerinnen
und bürger der eu ebenfalls vielfach wie
es geht um ein europa der menschen das
muss doch der kern sein
die müssen unser maßstab sein und wenn
wir uns da die situation anfang ist sie
eben eine schlechtere wie man wir
erinnern uns doch an die finanzkrise
hier ist auch heute mehrfach darüber
gesprochen worden und damals war es so
dass die verkäuferinnen die polizisten
der paket wurde die altenpflegerin die
haben letztlich das was banken
verursacht haben bezahlt mit
steuermitteln und das können wir doch
nicht akzeptieren und wir sehen doch bei
den schulen machen dabei herausgekommen
ist welche defizite die wir haben und
wie wird das diesmal sein
ich hätte mir gewünscht dass endlich mal
und das deutschland dazu initiativ
geworden wäre
diejenigen die profiteure der krise sind
die milliardär und multi millionäre in
ganz europa einen beitrag leisten zur
finanzierung eine europaweite habe
nirgends sagte aber für diese leute das
wäre meine deutsche initiativen geben
wenn du da modern aber die eu hat doch
in all den jahren und ich finde das
wirklich noch mal ein mal aufzählen die
hat doch vor allen dingen hingegen ein
soziales europa gearbeitet
seit 2011 hat die eu-kommission 63 mal
zu kürzungen im gesundheitswesen und zur
privatisierung von krankenhäusern
aufgerufen 50 mal hat die regierung zu
maßnahmen aufgerufen um steigende löhne
zu unterbinden 38 mal wurden anweisungen
zur reduzierung des kündigungsschutzes
gegeben frankreich wurde aufgefordert
die renten zu kürzen
das ist die realität und deshalb ist die
europäische union tief gespalten das ist
die reale situation
liebe kollegen blieben wer ein soziales
und bürgernahes europa verhindert nimmt
den menschen sicherheit und kontrolle
über erleben und der zerstört vor allem
vertrauen in politik und in europa es
ist doch ein treppenwitz dass
ausgerechnet der neoliberale boris
johnson auf diesem nährboden mit dem
slogan take control aus der eu
großbritannien geführt hat das ist doch
wirklich ein treppenwitz diese kampagne
war schwierig und voller lügen aber das
problem ist doch er hat an ein gefühl
der menschen angeschlossen dass dieses
europa kalt und teuer ist und da was
real is hat das funktioniert das muss
uns allen zu denken geben das ist doch
nicht nur ein kleines problem in
großbritannien das ist einfach ein
europäisches problem wo wir gemeinsam
etwas tun müssen dass die menschen leben
nicht sagen diese europäische union ist
kalt und da wird nur an geld gedacht
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen oder
scholz hat gesagt sie ist europa muss
politischer werden sehr richtig ja die
maßstab menschenwürde rechtsstaat die
müssen ganz oben stehen ohne jede frage
aber liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
europa befindet sich doch gerade in
diesem punkt in einer enorm schweren
krise
seit 2005 ist es zu keinem zeitpunkt
gelungen eine europäische
flüchtlingspolitik auf den weg zu
bringen
die humanität groß schreibt die
menschenrechte uneingeschränkt achtet
und die die lasten gerecht verteilt jede
woche ertrinken menschen im mittelmeer
werden in libyschen lagern menschen
gequält und erniedrigt die europäische
moral befindet sich in einem
schraubstock zwischen der libyschen
küstenwache und dem türkischen despoten
erdogan
das ist die wahrheit und das ist eine
europäische bankrott erklärt meine damen
werden
sie haben sicherlich noch mehr
schlaflose nächte in brüssel verbracht
als mit den ministerpräsidenten unseres
landes in der korona krise und es ist
wirklich so jeder manche vorwurf dahin
gemacht worden ist geht wirklich nicht
auf ihr konto und sie haben vielfach
schlimmeres verhindert das ist die
wahrheit
aber ich glaube dass es letztlich für
die ambitionen die wir mit europa haben
sollten zu wenig dass sie ihn dann als
vorsitzender der linksfraktion das sind
so momente als er gerade die
bundeskanzlerin noch mal persönlich
angesprochen hat da hätte man sich
gewünscht hätte da ohne maske gesessen
und man hätte ein wenig erkennen können
wie sie darauf reagiert hat annalena
baerbock ist die nächste rednerin und
wie ich schon sagte eine der
bewerberinnen um die nachfolge von
angela merkel präsident der geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr geehrte
frau bundeskanzlerin da das aller
wahrscheinlichkeit ihre netze letzte
große europapolitische rede hier im
bundestag gewesen ist möchte ich an
dieser stelle sagen sehr sehr viele
menschen in diesem land den dankbar
dafür dass sie in krisensituationen in
den letzten 16 jahren dieses europa
zusammengehalten haben gerade auch gegen
große widerstände aus ihrer eigenen
fraktion und vor allen dingen von ihrer
schwesterpartei
30 nicht mehr europa immer nur kurz dass
sich bei ersten schocks zu stabilisieren
in diesem jahrzehnt geht es darum
europas versprechen zu erneuern einen
klimagerechten wohlstand in europa zu
schaffen und gerechter wohlstand
bedeutet unsere chance die wir jetzt
haben unseren wirtschaftsraum der der
größte gemeinsame wirtschaftsraum
weltweit ist so zu modernisieren dass
wir auf den märkten der zukunft
klimaneutral eine chance haben und warum
weil das kein selbstzweck ist sondern
weil das die grundlage dafür ist die
stärke europas das sozial versprechen
die daseinsvorsorge für alle im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert sichern
und das ist der kitt der soziale kitt
der freiheits geht der europa
zusammenhängt gerade im wettstreit mit
autoritären regimen damit verteidigen
wir unsere liberale demokratie und
blickt auf die tagesordnung für diesen
europäischen rat und höre ich vor allen
dingen meine vorredner hier an dieser
stelle dann wiederholt sich doch
bekanntes die richtigen themen werden
angesprochen
doch die nötigen antworten für einen
wirklich europäischen aufbruch die sucht
man vergebens
wo ist das versprechen an die 450
millionen europäerinnen und europäer es
nach dieser pandemie wirklich besser zu
machen und nicht nur zu versprechen
europa hat mit dem green
einen guten plan vorlegen aber diesen
deal fehlt der pulsierende herz schlagen
auch mit leben zu füllen
weil die größte regierung dieses europas
das blockiert und mit kratos und mit
analyse allein sorry aber damit erneuern
wir europas versprechen nicht die beiden
regierungen kommt dass er fand sie
investiert jetzt aus der krise heraus
1,9 billionen dollar für energiewende
für infrastruktur um es in zukunft
besser zu machen
china tut das aus anderen motiven und
nichts desto trotz des mittlerweile
weltmeister bei den erneuerbaren agieren
und wir in deutschland die feiern sich
hier ja gerade alles für den recovery
plan dieser recovery plan steht
deutschland 25 milliarden euro
round about zur verfügung sie brüsten
sich damit wäre jetzt der erste der
danach gerufen hat ich weiß ganz genau
seit 2005 10 haben sie hier die
wirtschafts und währungsunion blockiert
und auch das ist europa in der familie
auf die füße doch bei und was machen sie
hier
als sie endlich erkannt
das ist richtig jetzt in europas zukunft
zu investieren
dann schauen wir uns das mal genauer an
es geht ja hier schließlich um den
europäischen rat und den recovery plan
und nicht um bewerbungsreden dann muss
man feststellen dass in diesem zeichen
dass in diesem deutsche polizei
eigentlich ein watt waren das wollen die
regeln der europäer die gemeinsam
beschlossen wurden auch dem europäischen
rat beim letzten mal
mindestens 37 prozent der gelder für
klimaschutz und 20 prozent der gelder
für digitalisierung damir in deutschland
ziemlichen nachholbedarf einzusetzen und
was machen sie schauen sie sich das mal
genauer an
80 prozent der maßnahmen für den
deutschen wiederaufbau zeiten waren
bereits vorher bestandteil des deutschen
konjunkturprogramm das ist nichts neues
sondern das ist alter wein in neuen
schläuchen und damit schaffen wir eine
kinderschutz
eine digitalisierung ist am institut für
sie nach gerechnet das sind ja nicht
meine zeit läppische 1 prozent aus dem
recovery fand gehen in deutschland in
den klimaschutz
und dann wundern sie sich jetzt in
fernseh talkshows wie kann das sein dass
die nächste generation um die ist ja
eigentlich steht und das
bundesverfassungsgericht ihn plötzlich
die leviten liest
ich sag s leben weil sie nicht nur das
versprechen an die nächste generation in
deutschland sondern das versprechen alle
europäerinnen und europäer wir gemeinsam
die unsere zukunft dieses versprechen
bleiben sie weiter aus und das müssen
wir ändern
wir brauchen eine deutschen
bundesregierung die mit vollem herzen
europäische kulinarisch und klima 936
und die dann auch entsprechend handelt
und nicht nur bis zur nächsten
landtagswahl denkt weil ein fan
vielleicht ein prozent kosten könnte wir
müssen gemeinsam einen klimaneutral
kontinen schaffen und europa kann dass
europa aus feinden freunde gemacht
europa kann es schaffen im nächsten
jahrzehnt den klimaneutralen weg
eingeschlagen und zum ersten
klimaneutralen kontinent dieser welt zu
werden meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren ich wollte an dieser stelle aber
auch sehr deutlich sagen das schaffen
wir indem wir das können ganze
versprechen europas erneuern
auch das versprechen zu unseren werten
und das bedeutet auch innerhalb europas
eine deutliche sprache zu finden
wenn die menschenrechte und dazu gehört
egal wen ich liebe ich habe meine
menschenrechte in anderen
ländern wie ungarn mit füßen getreten
werden und dazu gehört auch wählen sie
jetzt über flüchtlingspolitik reden zu
sehen was eine kroatischen grenze
passiert da werden kleine kinder und
familie mit push back zurückgedrängt und
das vertrauen in unsere demokratie
das versprechen europas zu erneuern das
schaffen wir nur wenn wir auch vertrauen
das die kraft unser werte größer ist als
einfache populistische sprüche und in
diesem sinne sagen wir sehr deutlich
anders als sie meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren von der union jetzt ist
der moment wir haben ein fenster auf
opportunity wir haben 2020 die mit
schirms in den usa wir haben ich komme
zum schluss wir haben die
präsidentschaftswahlen in den in
frankreich nutzen wir dieses gemeinsame
fenster wir werden nicht drei monate
abwarten und dann sagen wir machen
kassensturz wir wollen europa jetzt
erneuern
mit unseren europäischen freunden und
nachbarn zusammen denn unsere zukunft
ist europa erneuern wir das versprechen
europas und zwar jetzt machen wir es
besser
das sind wir 450 millionen bürgerinnen
und bürgern schuldig herzlichen dank
annalena baerbock parteivorsitzende von
bündnis 90 die grünen natürlich
kanzlerkandidatin von bündnis 90/die
grünen und einen satz kann sie schon mal
den wie kanzlerin berühmt gemacht hat
das schaffen wir
nächster redner in dieser aussprache zur
regierungserklärung zum europäischen rat
die natürlich auch noch eine andere
dimension hat weil es die letzte
aussprache zu einer regierungserklärung
der bundeskanzlerin angela merkel ist
ich weiß dass es ihre letzte rede ist
und dazu erteile ich ihnen jetzt das
wort und ganz schnell christian
mit für die csu war landschafts minister
landwirtschaftsminister und er war auch
parlamentarischer staatssekretär im
verteidigungsministerium will kollegen
kollegen
herzlichen dank aber frau baerbock ich
kann sie von einer sorge befreien eine
bewerbungsrede war das nicht sehr
geehrte damen und herren
mein europa ist ein europa mit grenzen
die nicht trennen
mein europa ist da in europa vieler
vieler menschen vieler länder
mein europa steht für vielfalt für
frieden für demokratie helmut kohl hat
mit blick auf die europäische und
deutsche geschichte immer gewarnt
vergesst die kleine nicht gewisser weise
ist das die doktrin unserer außen- und
europapolitik wir pflegen auch und
gerade mit den staaten enge beziehungen
die nicht im konzert der großen
mitspielen
meine zukunft in europa spielt sich in
zukunft zwei flugstunden von hier ab
keine 1500 kilometer von hier leben
menschen in einem wunderschönen teil
europas die fahren davon träumen dazu zu
gehören
zufrieden und zu guten lebenschancen zu
europa zu uns am ersten august trete ich
in sarajevo das amt des hohen
repräsentanten für bosnien herzegowina
an
ich danke der bundeskanzlerin und der
gesamten bundesregierung für diese im
kontext der verstärkten befassung mit
der situation der länder im westbalkan
entstanden der initiative und der
internationalen gemeinschaft für die
übertragung dieser spannenden
herausforderten sicher nicht einfachen
aufgabe ich tue das
mit dem festen willen durch klugen 1 hat
es der zur verfügung stehenden mittel
aus den friedensvereinbarungen der
staten einen entscheidenden beitrag
dahingehend zu leisten dass die narben
in der region nicht wieder aufbrechen
dazu ist es ist dieses immer noch nötige
amt auch mit seinen exekutiv
möglichkeiten dar
es gewährleistet neben der unterstützung
des landes auf dem weg in die eu
auch die politische präsenz der
weltgemeinschaft zuvorderst für die
sicherstellung der territorialen
integrität bosnien herzegowinas nach
manchen non paper sind in den letzten
wochen konnte man seine sorgen darüber
haben insbesondere unsere freunde und
partner in washington auch mit
europäischen staaten und der
weltgemeinschaft in deuten die daten so
in und für europa gehandelt wie
präsident biden das letzte woche in
brüssel als amerikanischer richtung für
die sicherheit europas genannt hat s
secret obsession eine heilige
verpflichtung gut für uns dass die usa
wieder zurück sind und wir europäer
werden unseren beitrag leisten ob im
baltikum auf dem balkan oder wo immer in
europa oder seiner nachbarschaft der
genozid von srebrenica und andere
monströse kriegsverbrechen müssen im
kollektiven bewusstsein von uns allen
von uns europäern als mahnung gewärtig
bleiben
nicht nur wegen dieser schlimmen
erfahrungen dürfen wir den westbalkan
diese schlüsselregion europas unseren
südöstlichen campus der vielfältigkeit
nicht vergessen und müssen den blick
darauf richten
der weg dorthin ist aber sofort an
bringt auch viele verpflichtungen für
diese länder und ihre gesellschaften
witzig dass wir gut daran tun in
sichtweite liegende zwischenstationen zu
markieren
zwischenstationen damit für die
bürgerinnen und bürger vorteile und
nutzen der eu nicht nur ein utopisches
konstrukt scheinen sondern erfahrbar
werden realität werden
können europa darf nicht stehenbleiben
europa muss sich weiterentwickeln und
muss wege suchen die konkrete antworten
geben
die erreichbaren verlässlich sind die
entscheidende frage ist machen wir aus
der größe europas eine schwerfälligkeit
oder doch eine stärke europas
europa spielt in einer globalisierten
welt nur dann eine gewichtige rolle
wenn unsere werte in einem
konzentrierten ringen miteinander zu
einem gemeinsamen agenda reifen
wir brauchen einen offenen binnenmarkt
und solidarität in der krise und danach
wir brauchen aber auch keine transfers
schulden union
wir brauchen auch eine vernünftige
sicherung der europäischen außengrenzen
wir alle wollen wir uns der
eigenständigkeit aber das ist kein
argument gegen eine europäische
verfassung
jeder kann seine identität pflegen das
heißt aber nicht dass nationalistische
überheblichkeit den ton angeben darf auf
dem balkan waren wir die eu die usa noch
vor wenigen jahren militärisch gefordert
lassen sie uns gemeinsam alles
daransetzen dass wir dort und anderswo
in europa in zukunft nur friedlich
gefordert sind sehr verehrte kolleginnen
und kollegen
liebe frau bundeskanzlerin über
ministerpräsident vor 31 jahren am 20
dezember 1990 saß ich das erste mal in
diesem hohen haus noch nicht in diesem
saal das war noch vor der vor dem umbau
ein jahr nach der wende in einer anderen
zeit
helmut kohl war bundeskanzler der
kanzler der einheit der kanzler europas
hans dietrich genscher sein
außenminister und parteivorsitzender und
willy brandt war alterspräsident 31
jahre ist das her 31 unglaubliche jahre
damals wurde deutsche geschichte
geschrieben die deutsche einheit für die
ich 1981 noch vor diesem haus mit meinen
freunden der jungen union demonstriert
hatte war friedlich erreicht der
zwei-plus-vier-vertrag gerade auf den
weg gebracht und die zukunft
deutschlands von anderen mit
wagen ohne diese vier andere länder und
ihre einigkeit werden wir heute nicht da
wo wir stehen
ich bin dankbar für diese zeit für
unsere demokratie ihnen für konstruktive
politik für das bestreben die welt ein
stück besser zu machen
ich bin dankbar meinen wählern für ihr
vertrauen
den kolleginnen und kollegen die im
deutschen bundestag über alle fraktionen
will ich welche ansprechen der
csu-landesgruppe meiner politischen von
fraktion allen heimat alexander dobrindt
stellvertretend für die csu-landesgruppe
meiner bundestagsfraktion auf brinkhaus
und allen anderen die mit denen ich
zusammenarbeiten durfte meiner familie
danke ich für das verständnis in all den
jahren viele von ihnen werde ich wieder
sehen hoffe ich in meiner neuen aufgabe
ob in brüssel berlin oder sarajevo ich
freue mich darauf
danke sehr
da klang jetzt doch noch ein wenig
wehmut mit der stimme von christian
schmidt mdb seit 1990 über kollege
christian schmidt sie haben sich hier
denn über drei jahrzehnten ihrer
parlamentarischen arbeit in vielen
funktionen große verdienste für unser
parlament in unser land erworben
dafür danke ich ihnen wir alle wünschen
ihnen für ihre neue aufgabe als hoher
repräsentant der vereinten nation in
bosnien und herzegowina alles gute und
viel erfolg kommen und dann noch einmal
eine persönliche würdigung durch die
bundestagspräsident wolfgang schäuble
der nächste redner in dieser debatte ist
martin schuld sind haben sie
möglicherweise heute morgen schon an
unseren mikrofonen erlebt und gehört
jetzt seine rede hier in richtung
regierungserklärung und es ist nur
mutmaßlich auch seine letzte im
bundestag ihre kolleginnen kollegen die
pandemie hat uns herausgefordert sie hat
den geist der solidarität zwischen den
staaten und den inneren zusammenhalt
unserer gesellschaft auf eine harte
probe gestellt
querulanten und verschwörungs erzähler
haben alles getan um uns auseinander zu
treiben
der europäische rat zu dem sie heute
fahren frau merkel tritt an einem tag
zusammen an dem die bundesweite inzidenz
266 liegt in ganz europa einschränkungen
zurückgenommen werden im kampagnen
laufen
das repräsentiert
die botschaft europa hat
zusammengehalten es ist nicht gelungen
uns auseinander zu treiben und wenn die
anderthalb jahre die hinter uns liegen
eine schlussfolgerung zu lassen dann
diese einigkeit macht stark
das ist der geist in dem europa
gestaltet werden muss
viel hängt davon ab schon vor vier
jahren haben wir als sozialdemokraten im
koalitionsvertrag durchsetzen können
dass zum ersten mal in einem deutschen
regierungsprogramm europa an erster
stelle stand denn europa meine damen und
herren verdient es dass seine stärkung
höchste deutsche regierungspolitik ist
und diese regierung hat europa gestärkt
für die stärkung der europäischen union
stehen zwei projekt ersten in besonderer
weise zum ersten dass die eu bei dem
wiederaufbau von endlich autonomen
geldern den finanzmärkten aufnehmen kann
in diesen tagen fällt überall in europa
der startschuss für milliardenschwere
investitions und reformprojekte was ist
das für ein kontrast im gegensatz zu vor
zehn jahren als besuch aus brüssel vor
allen dingen bedeutete kürzungen bei
renten und sozialleistungen was machen
wir jetzt stand arbeitslosigkeit und
austerität wie damals steht europa jetzt
vermutet aufbau und aufbruch das ist das
euro
dass wir wollen das zweite projekt
google amazon facebook und apple zahlen
jetzt endlich in zukunft steuern auch
hier in deutschland dank der globalen
mindestbesteuerung von 15 prozent die
dge 7 jetzt anstreben das ist ein
schritt zu konkreten mehr gerechtigkeit
und ich halte das für einen der größten
erfolge in der internationalen politik
der letzten jahre und neben dem
wiederaufbau von ist das ein großer
erfolg deutscher europapolitik und er
trägt die handschrift des bundes
finanzminister der bundesrepublik
deutschland oder schweiz
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen sehr
geehrte damen und herren ich bin froh
dass ich helfen konnte
all das und vieles mehr mit auf den weg
zu bringen
das ist jetzt hier meine letzte rede in
einem parlament insgesamt 27 jahren als
parlamentarier 23 jahre im europäischen
parlament und vier hier im deutschen
bundestag
der größte teil meiner parlamentarischen
arbeit galt der festen verankerung
deutschlands in europa und der stärkung
europas durch deutschland weil ich
zutiefst davon überzeugt bin auch als
ein kind meiner generation zutiefst
davon überzeugt bin dass ein starkes
europa ein einiges ökonomisch sozial und
kulturell erfolgreich zusammenarbeiten
des europa die beste grundlage für eine
sichere zukunft in frieden und wohlstand
für die nächsten generationen auf dem
gesamten kontinent ist
geografisch gesehen liegt deutschland in
der mitte dieses kontinents von neun
nachbarländern umgeben von denen heute
keines mehr angst vor deutschland hat
und auch nicht haben muss
bezogen auf die über tausendjährige
geschichte unserer nation ist das
vielleicht der grösste erfolg in diesem
bewusstsein meine damen und herren habe
ich als abgeordneter gearbeitet ich
finde vertreter der bürgerinnen und
bürger zusammen ist die höchste ehre die
einem in einem republikanischen staat
zuteil werden kann
für dieses einzigartige privileg bin ich
den wählerinnen und wählern zutiefst zu
dank verpflichtet
dankbar bin ich all denjenigen denen ich
hier im hause begegnet bin um in denen
ich zusammenarbeiten durfte neben den
erfolgen die wir erzielen konnten neben
den herausforderungen der korona krise
haben uns jedoch in dieser
legislaturperiode ein phänomen
genauso gewöhnlicher form bewegt das ist
die neue gewalt des
rechtsextremistischen terrors der feigen
mord an walther wird der schändliche
anschlag in halle die
verabscheuungswürdigen attentat in hanna
die atmosphäre von enthemmter sprache
und aggressiver intoleranz die zu
solchen taten führt hat in dieser
wahlperiode auch einzug in dieses haus
gehalten
ich wünsche mir dass alle demokratinnen
und demokraten im nächsten deutschen
bundestag wieder eine brandmauer gegen
den hass errichten das kein tabubruch
geduldet wird dass die grenze des
sagbaren nicht jeden tag weiter
verschoben wird
ich für mich und meine person werde mich
bemühen an anderer stelle wo ich
weiterarbeiten werde genau dafür
einzusetzen
für eine klare haltung gegen rechts für
eine gerechte gesellschaft für vielfalt
für respekt und toleranz und vor allen
dingen für ein stark ist ein friedliches
soziales und demokratisches europa
vielen dank
mahnung und warnung vor
rechtsextremismus und intoleranz durch
martin schulz dem langjährigen
parlamentarier dem ehemaligen
parlamentspräsidenten eben der
europäischen union parteivorsitzende der
spd ist der gewesen kanzlerkandidat vor
gut vier jahren geben
angela merkel im wettbewerb hat er
gestanden und jetzt hat er auch noch mal
in seiner letzten rede hier im deutschen
bundestag einen flammenden appell für
europa gehalten
ich danke auch ihn für die jahrzehnte
ihres einsatzes für freiheitliche
parlamentarische demokratie in unserem
land und vor allem in europa und wir
wünschen ihnen für neue aufgaben für
ihren weiteren lebensweg für ihr
weiteres engagement vor allem für europa
alles gute matthäus bereits vorsitzender
der friedrich ebert stiftung also der
spd-nahen politischen stiftung und da
wird er sicher das eine oder andere mal
sich noch zu wort melden frauke petry
ist die nächste rednerin
sehr geehrter präsident sehr geehrte
damen und herren heute am johannistag
2021 für diese schal des bundes kann
schon gerade jetzt die debatte verlassen
hat debattieren wir nämlich zum letzten
mal genau über ihre amtszeit frau
bundeskanzlerin über deutschlands
politik in europa die bundeskanzlerin
präsentiert sich hier gerne als
klimakanzlerin
dabei hat sie die fatale abkehr von der
kernenergie als erste regierungschefin
in deutschland zu verantworten dass
dabei die technik freiheitlichen grünen
politisch hofiert wurden dass dadurch
die nutzung von kohle und gas
vorübergehend zu einem vermehrten co2
ausstoß geführt hat ist ergebnis
gefühliger entscheidungen nicht jedoch
vorausschauender politik von einem 1
fortschrittlichen energieexporteur hat
sich deutschland unter der führung von
frau merkel auf den weg zum
energiepolitischen entwicklungsland
begeben mit den höchst energiepreisen in
europa die deutsche außenpolitik ist
spätestens seit der euro- und migrations
krise unter druck
frau merkel wird sich gern
multilateraler kooperation tatsächlich
aber verschleudern wir als deutschland
milliarden von steuermitteln und viele
fleißige eu-bürger und zwingen unsere
europäischen partner durch nationale
entscheidungen die grenzöffnung 2015 die
folgen dieser fehlentscheidung faktisch
auf das ist keine kooperation auf
augenhöhe
das ist maximal deutsch-französischer
zentralismus unter einer europäischen
krank habe frau merkel unterstützt mit
einem weiteren flüchtlingsboot er begann
eine politik in der die schlechten
bilder einfach an andere grenze verbannt
werden und zeitplan dafür bis 2024
weiteres
6 milliarden euro damit unterstützen wir
als deutsches als deutsche
bundesregierung als deutschland
insgesamt erdogans national
islamistische regime das gleichzeitig
völkerrechtswidrig in syrien
einmarschiert ist und zusammen mit
aserbaidschan gegen armenien zu felde
zieht um letztlich an den kanten
türkische union als neuen machtfaktor in
der welt zu schaffen
dabei ist die türkei nato-partner aber
offenbar einer die niemand mehr im griff
hat
1 tl damen und herren ist viel viel
näher bei den bürgern und das ist corona
die politik der bundeskanzlerin hat die
angst soll die wissenschaftliche
methoden und das instrument des
einsparens und abschotten der bürger zur
neuen maxime der krankheitsbekämpfung
erhoben werde die
politikwissenschaftlerin oder kempf vom
völkerrecht her
dann könnte ich das erklären für eine
naturwissenschaftlerin ist diese politik
eine bankrotterklärung
wir wollen in diesem land freiheit
wettbewerb und den mut zur kontroverse
in wissenschaft und politik
gleichermaßen und das mehr denn je unter
der führung von frau bundeskanzlerin
merkel wurden private infantile macht
vorstellungen in fast allen bereichen
der politik zum neuen politischen
maßstab erhoben das ist die abkehr von
einem aufgeklärten wissenschaftlichen
gesellschaftsverständnis und das
bedauere ich sehr
ich hoffe dass von merkels nachfolger
armin laschet immer mehr politischen
pragmatismus verfügt und die moralisch
überladen argumentation hinter sich
lässt das nämlich ist unsere aufgabe als
politiker die wir gewählt sind um uns
primär um die bedürfnisse unserer bürger
zu kümmern
herzlichen dank frauke petry war unter
anderem vorsitzende der afg wird dem
nächsten bundestag auch nicht mehr
angehören ob ihr buch requiem für die
afd
da noch mal größere wellen schlägt das
wird sich weisen die heck der ihn ja
auch parteispenden vorwürfe an den
jetzigen co vorsitzenden leuten der weiß
das zurück wir werden das beobachten
katja leica dc letzte rednerin in dieser
aussprache vize fraktionsvorsitzende in
der unionsfraktion
finanzkrise migration pandemie unserem
europa wurde hier viel abverlangt und
egal welche krise wir als cdu csu
standen immer im zentrum der
problemlösung den linken und grünen
waren wir in europa oft zu streng wenn
wir auf die einhaltung von
verschuldungsquoten gepocht haben und er
hilft auch lautstärke nicht liebe frau
bernburg es gibt auch so was wie
generationengerechte finanzen und der
rechte rand hier im haus was uns quasi
nichts weniger als permanente
rechtsbruch vor
und das ausgerechnet beim euro derzeit
stärksten währung der welt
und wenn die urteile von rechts und
links so ausfallen dann kann man sagen
dass wir einiges richtig gemacht haben
mit großem einsatz und viel kraft haben
wir zwölf jahre das haus europas
zusammengehalten und das mit einer
kanzlerin die wie keine zweite für
europa steht und es waren nächtelange
gipfel sie war immer diejenige die am
längsten fit war und mit ihrer
versöhnenden und besonnenen art hat sie
entscheidend dazu beigetragen dass die
27 mitgliedsstaaten beisammen geblieben
sind ein herzliches dankeschön an angela
merkel
und ich wünsche mir dass wir auch nach
der bundestagswahl ein kanzler haben der
jeden tag daran arbeitet unsere
europäische union ein stück besser zu
machen und ich finde das hat armin
laschet gerade heute noch einmal
leidenschaftlich deutlich gemacht europa
ist für ihn und uns als cdu csu fraktion
eine echte herzensangelegenheit und
liebe kolleginnen und kolleginnen ich
bin davon überzeugt dass wir unsere
chancen nutzen müssen um bei den großen
transformations- themen digitalisierung
klimaschutz unserer zeit wieder nach
vorne zu kommen und wir sollten uns sich
selbst bedauern dass wir kein
europäisches google facebook oder
twitter haben sondern eben durch
gezielte förderung von start-ups
forschung und innovation für bessere
bedingungen für unsere klügsten köpfe zu
sorgen und das digitale eu cobit
zertifikat ist ja ein tolles beispiel
fast 30 millionen menschen haben es
allein schon in deutschland die usa
haben kein einheitliches digitales
zertifikat wir haben es in 27
mitgliedstaaten made in europe und
darauf können wir auch mal stolz sein
und wenn wir schon beim thema
digitalisierung sind dann ist für mich
auf 1 wichtigen ich möchte explizit
heute morgen hier ansprechen
neben den datenschutz auch nicht in
absurde höhen zu schrauben
das sehen wir in nationalen debatten und
das sehen wir in brüssel
und da liebe grüne können sie auch sehr
viel noch von uns lernt auch das
internet ist kein rechtsfreier raum
die menschen sollen auch da sicher sein
und für uns heißt das zum beispiel dass
der kinderschutz immer über dem schutz
der verbindungsdaten von verbrechern
stehen muss und die debatten der letzten
jahren dazu zeigen im digitalen raum
brauchen wir sicherheit im digitalen
raum brauchen wir eine
nannte vernunft und das geht eben am
besten mit der cdu/csu und nicht mit
irgendwelchen ideologischen debatten und
vernunft
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ist auch
ein super stichwort für das thema
klimaschutz und es ist richtig dass die
europäische union hier vorangegangen ist
mit dem green deal und das übrigens zu
einer zeit wo sich die amerikaner vom
klima abkommen unter trump abwenden
wollen der hat ursula von der leyen
mutig gehandelt und dieses thema
entschlossen voran gegangen und ich
möchte ganz offen sagt ich würde ungern
hier aus der letzten sitzungswoche des
deutschen bundestags nach hause kommt zu
meinen kindern und sagen sorry liebe
kinder wir machen nur zwei prozent der
weltbevölkerung europa aus deswegen
machen wir nichts am klimaschutz und
hier blockiert auch niemand frau werber
und schon gar nicht die cdu csu fraktion
und hier taumelt auch keine europäische
union herr bartsch die europäische union
hat hierfür gebiet riesen und ich freue
mich dass china und die usa in den
positiven wettbewerb um die besten
technologien für klimaschutz
eingestiegen sind und liebe kolleginnen
kollegen ich bin da sehr sehr
zuversichtlich wir haben
spitzenforschung nicht nur in
deutschland sondern auch in europa
spitzenunternehmen und innovation und
einer unserer wirtschafts pioniere
werner von siemens wusste schon vor über
200 jahren dass man eben mit standards
märkte erschließen und dauerhaft
wohlstand sichert und auch hier sind wir
als cdu csu konservativ wir wollen eine
klimaneutrale union
wir wollen dass die wirtschaft läuft wir
wollen dass die menschen arbeit haben
und für uns ist ganz klar klimaschutz
muss eben auch wachstumstreiber seien
nur das ist nachhaltig da müssen wir in
europa hin packen wir es an und übrigens
frau weigel auch mal mit freude im
herzen
für das erfolgreichste friedensprojekt
der welt herzlichen dank
kala kato unionsfraktion wo sie
stellvertretende vorsitzender ist hat
die aussprache ende beziehungsweise war
die letzte rednerin in dieser aussprache
zur regierungserklärung von
bundeskanzlerin merkel die ist schon
unterwegs zumindest nicht mehr im
plenarsaal